Richard what was the like really
disgusting shits the guys were all
talking about [ __ ] and I was like
even I was getting sick well we had a
bunch of Stories of the staff [ __ ]
like yeah well it was Gary mement
Richard Chris Ronnie and Sal but Richard
topped them all of course of course all
right here I'll give you a quiz Robin a
[ __ ] quiz how's this this staffer farted
at work ended up [ __ ] his pants at
Sirius XM he took his soiled underwear
in a plastic bag and buried it in a
garbage can on the 37th floor no one
found out who is that somebody who would
be you know embarrassed enough to take
his
dirty underwear to the 37th floor I'm
gonna say that was Gary
good guess but it was Ronnie Ronnie the
Limo Driver Mom
did you sit your pants in the in the
building I was taking a leak and I
farted and hit my pants
like a full [ __ ] or like some little
little nugget no it it was like a loose
deal you know
got it off right away I took it up to 37
and threw it in the bathroom up there in
the garbage can that's where all the
executives are yeah they it's poor
employees up there fun times for your
contribution yep yep all right all right
I'll give you another one this staffer
[ __ ] in a stranger's bathtub at a high
school house party
the staffer was coughing at the party a
bully said the staffer was getting
everyone sick and threw him out of the
house he was so humiliated he snuck back
into the house and he squeezed out a
very thick log into the bully's bathtub
I can't imagine anybody but Sal doing
that brilliant you're exactly right of
course Robin you want me to do well yeah
you know if you had gotten that wrong I
would have been very shocked good for
you that is horrible what what how is
the guy bullying you
I remember I was sitting on a couch and
it was a really cute girl next to me and
I had a really good wrap going but I had
that you know that cloth it almost
sounds like a whooping cough it was in
the I don't know and the guy's like hey
man he's like you're getting everybody
sick here you gotta go and they
literally picked me up and they escorted
me out of the house
oh my God it was terrible so I'm sitting
on the stoop and I'm pissed off my
friends inside he's drinking beers
having a blast I had to take a piss I
felt the [ __ ] coming and I just there
was the bathtub I just dropped my pants
I went into the bathtub and I just
pushed out a huge [ __ ] and I ran out of
there I don't even think I wiped my ass
because I panicked after that because
these guys would really kill me if they
found out
and so you never heard his story in
school going around that hey over at
so-and-so's house
yeah the only person who knows is my
best friend who I went home with and I
told him afterwards and he thought it
was brilliant he was so proud of me when
I did that
he thought it was brilliant but you know
I think the reason that friend
he becomes a good friend Sal you're the
Einstein of [ __ ] I gotta tell you
okay I'll give you one more before
Richard is
this staffer once dragged his own [ __ ]
all over his house after running
downstairs to catch a delivery he rushed
to wipe his butt on the upstairs toilet
but a piece of poop fell on the floor he
must have accidentally stepped on it he
ran downstairs
to get the door and when he turned
around there was [ __ ] all over the house
finish what you were doing toilet paper
swim
I think it's Mehmet I gave you the hint
s
that you did a bunch of different things
Gary
Gary was Home Alone he hasn't he didn't
tell his wife for years
uh Gary really Robin asked the key
question what the [ __ ] is so important
that you have to rush downstairs and get
[ __ ] all over yourself so I wasn't fully
Home Alone Mary was out of the house and
I think Jackson was a baby right so I'm
upstairs in the toilet the baby's
sleeping so somebody saw ding ding ding
ding like ringing the bell so I was like
I gotta go [ __ ] get this door before
they wake the baby up you know and so
whatever it was it was a delivery it was
like a package I was like oh thank you
whatever when I go to go back upstairs
there's [ __ ] on the stairs right so then
I'm like I'm like just blame your son I
take my sneaker off and there's [ __ ] on
the bottom of my sneaker so I follow the
trail and it leads back to the bathroom
I got it cleaned up it was all over the
place Howard everywhere wow well all
right Richard since you're the grossest
one out there you tell your [ __ ] story
so I was on tour in the 90s and we were
in Finland
um and we were flying to Greece which is
a really long flight it's like all the
way across Europe and I hate flying so
this is bad back in the days where you
could just drag a case of beer right
into the airport and drink in the
waiting room so I drank this super super
strong beer for hours while we waited
for our flight by the time I got on the
flight I was shithoused I was wasted I
ended up puking all down the aisle
running to the bathroom puking all the
way back to my seat there was a trail
all in the aisle so I had brutal alcohol
poisoning so we get to the hotel I lay
in bed and all of a sudden I I
projectile [ __ ] all over the bed while
I'm laying there
how do you do that yeah all right I was
laying on my side and and it I I think I
had like I was so I had vomited kind of
on my clothes so I was I think I was
naked and so I just [ __ ] like all over
the sheets and the blanket and
everything rock and roll yeah yeah oh it
was very rock and roll out but uh except
without no chicks anywhere around I [ __ ]
all over the blanket all over even on
the floor I think a little bit and then
so I gathered the the comforter the
sheets everything threw them under the
bed and and just kind of played Dumb and
uh and when he played um
who did you play dumb too well because I
was sharing a room with a band mate and
he was out sightseeing he came back and
he saw no sheets on the bed I was like
what happened here
I don't know it was some excuse I was
like oh I think there were bed bugs
through the sheets down came to the maid
and so I finally started to feel a
little better and and left and went uh
sightseeing and I came back a couple
hours later and there were new sheets on
the bed oh and uh so for housekeepers I
know and I looked under the bed I was
like oh I hope they didn't find the
shitty sheets and of course they did and
I looked under the bed and the shitty
sheets were gone oh my God I felt
horrible I I didn't have like at Greece
money to give a tip or anything and
grease money
[Laughter]
my man I'm not even gonna bother your
[ __ ] story you can't top that one you
just I know I'm a normal human being my
[ __ ] story is from when I was like five
I I was even included it yeah that's
understandable you know I mean what is
it so Howard I can't tell you how many
times in the office at least once a
month we're just doing our work and all
of a sudden I hear uh oh
I'm like what buddy I just [ __ ] myself
it's just like him it's it's the way we
would burp Richard shits his pants by
the way Richard is [ __ ] right now I
don't know if you realize it